les antennes relais de téléphonie mobile
à nouveau au coeur de l'actualité 20
nouveaux projets seraient prévus sur le
territoire de l'agglomération dont 10 à
tour certains riverains s'en inquiète
une réunion est d'ailleurs prévue demain
en mairie tour avec d'abord les
opérateurs puis ensuite les associations
de riverains dont les robins des toits
une association qui fait ses propres
mesures mais quelle briffaud
michel habite ici depuis 29 ans mais
depuis 2007 cinq antennes relais ont
pris place en face de chez lui cacher
dans de fausses cheminées et même si
aucune étude scientifique n'a réussi à
trouver de liens il pense qu'il ya plus
qu'une coïncidence moque de femelles les
acouphènes évidemment qui est intérieure
et puis le fait pas tout et l'autre la
stabilité évidemment qu'on craque match
oui mes yeux quand j'aurai comme ça à la
maison ça ne fait pas très chaud à
l'extérieur un soin aux champs ou dans
n'importe quel magasin je marchais dans
le nom des gens peut pas se rendre
compte de la façon que j'ai deux de me
déplacer le représentant des robins des
toits relève presque 3 volts par mètre
chez michel s'est largement en dessous
des banques françaises qui tolèrent
jusqu'à 61 volts mais pour l'association
avec l'arrivée du nouvel opérateur free
les antennes vont se multiplier
par le passé les robins des toits de
tours ont déjà réussi à faire stopper un
projet d'implantation aux halles et plus
récemment près d'une école à tours nord
mais pour eux le combat continue on veut
entériner les décisions qu'ils sont
déjà prévus on veut ensuite parlé des
nouveaux projets en dix ans attendait il
faut peut-être attendre que la
législation se sont modifiés et puis on
veut aussi porter l'attention sur les
points noirs existants comme celui là
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
cette action de sensibilisation parce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui des situations un
peu partout dans la ville qui sont
certainement critiques comme celle là il
ya 70 sites donc il ya potentiellement
d'autres problèmes comme ça riverains et
l'association viennent de se réunir pour
créer un collectif rassemblant une
cinquantaine de membres leur objectif
s'unir pour être plus fort et faire
entendre leur voix surtout lors de la
réunion de concertation qui se tiendra
ce jeudi représentants de la ville
opérateurs et collectif tourangeau
discuteront entre autres de
l'implantation de 20 nouvelles antennes
relais sur l'agglomération tourangelle